what's up guys today we're gonna be
taking an in-depth look at the course
here h100 IV - all they want liquid
cooler 240 millimeters so let's get
started once you get the plastic wrap
off the Box just a simple tab on the
right side I can pull open the whole
right side comes open and Teresa talked
on inside the piece of styrofoam and
right here there's the manual and some
other papers
in the middle right here there's a -
included pins it comes straight out and
we have a little for pinkie boy
you know this through the mountain today
we need and the amount and tell but guys
this year we're getting a.m. for any of
the rising once make sure you guys order
the free am tour Mount from the Coursera
mine has an increment newer versions
have included but if you don't get it
and make sure that you are separate from
them it's free
finally juice the radiator and their
cooler itself there's a basketball on
this lady just comes straight off
so here's a radiator underwater block
the first cable is a 3-pin connector
that connects into the a i/o connector
on the motherboard and if you don't have
one of those we just connect this on to
the fan connector it does the same thing
as long as it is there enough voltage at
which there should be and then there's
two other four pin pwm fans that come
off with that so this thing powers its
own fan so you don't need more than one
fan header to power this area
now let's take a look at what comes
inside the bag
so inside the back there is some booze
some long screws down a community radio
2d fans the Amthor bracket and if you
guys didn't get this make sure you order
from that of course to his website
here's the black just a backplate for
Intel the Intel one is already installed
on the water block so you need to
install it here is the USB 2.0 front
panel connector at this connects to in
order to make thermals and fan speed and
stuff like that to them Peter if you
want to use that you need to download
corsair link well guys i hope you guys
enjoyed that detailed look as to what
comes inside the box of the course here
h100 ib2 I'm gonna be making a review
video of this cooler and going up the
software and seeing how it performs the
thermals and stuff like that my review
so make sure it's like the link in
description if you guys are interested
but that's all for now guys if you like
this video and make sure to give it a
like if you guys loved it and would like
to see more videos just like this make
sure to subscribe and hit the bell
notification but that's all for now and
until the next video bye